comes right in terms of uh covid was
there's maybe a week or two weeks where
it got really serious but again it was
still over a two week period it wasn't
just like one day kovit's not here
next day covid's here right and kind of
that that type of
very sharp market reaction
yeah yeah and i think here that
definitely happens on an election and so
from an asset allocation standpoint
do you basically go into the election
almost with like
uh i'll call like a trump presidency
plan and a biden
uh presidency plan and then depending on
who wins the election
you know the directive can change based
on who that that presidential
uh candidate ends up being or do you go
into it more
with uh maybe a range and you say you
know if it's a landslide
then we're going to be on the most
extreme end of this if it's not uh maybe
we have kind of a more moderate
uh change to asset allocation like how
do you just think about that going into
such a binary event like this
so it's a great question and our clients
have been asking this a lot lately no
surprise and my answer is
we never want to make grand or sweeping
portfolio changes
around a binary event because it's so
easy and the odds are very high that
you're going to be on the wrong side of
that
outcome and so our best advice is really
to maintain a well-diversified portfolio
into through around binary events
but take stock of what the exposures are
in your portfolio be mindful of
positioning
and if there's something that you're
really concerned about and i can talk
about
some of those things then it may be
worth making adjustments but we're never
going to be
all one portfolio or all one another
depending on the administration that is
an important component
to the path forward for the markets but
it's not the only component and i would
just say
at the end of the day really because
kovid is
still very much alive and well here it
has not faded into the backdrop even
though the data has started to look
better
um over the course of the summer we're
now starting to see
a resurgence in western europe and there
is the potential
for the covid curves to start hooking
higher here
in a more sustained way in the us and so
at the end of the day we actually think
that is much more critical to the pace
and timing of policy changes coming out
of washington
than just the election itself that is
it's a bit of a mixed blessing
i don't know if that's kind of a crazy
thing to say when you're in a pandemic
but
it will slow down grand and sweeping
policy changes so if we have a change in
control
that new administration and whoever is
controlling congress is still going to
have their hands full
trying to figure out this covet story
not likely to start slapping you know
big tax increases
in right out of the gate in the new year
and so we may ultimately get them
right but it's a little bit of a slower
longer drawn out process in our view
and so i think that will help to calm
equity markets in particular but just
public markets in general
if we were to get a change in control
some of the things that we're thinking
about though
um i can talk through so the the biggie
if trump were to stay
in control and get reelected is what
happens on the trade policy front
if you think back to 2018 and even 2019
every time he put out a tweet
talking about trade policy or
a change in tariffs or an escalation
whether it be china mexico our trading
partners in europe and so on
the market freaked out and yes that is a
technical term
i mean the market just hated
the stance that he was taking around
trade policy
for better or worse that has faded
largely
into the backdrop so we got a handshake
agreement if you will
uh pre-covered at the end of 2019 that
was a very welcome
you know sigh of relief um that that
effectively was now in the rear view
mirror and the market could charge a
path higher
but we're starting to see that rhetoric
pick up again and so to the extent that
he gets reelected we think that will be
a key focal point
and he will take a much harder line
stance and i think that will
be something that the market is going to
have to wrestle with
for a while yet we might see more
tariffs we might see more
blocking of deals i mean the list could
go on and on depending on
what he decides to do but that will
inject a pretty significant amount of
uncertainty
i don't think it's really getting the
attention
that it deserves in the media in the
press and really in the markets that's
that's a real
significant headwind and i would say
from a
portfolio positioning standpoint it
would be a big negative for emerging
markets
we do have exposure to emerging markets
we continue to like emerging markets we
think it's one of the most
if not most attractive equity asset
classes across the globe
they've handled covid on a relatively
better basis
i'm not talking china necessarily just
all of emerging markets has done a
collectively better job so they've
entered it and exited first
they've seen a second wave it's been
very mild they've been able to control
it
earnings growth has held up much better
than every other part of the world and
we're seeing
actually a really significant
acceleration projected
for earnings growth in 2021 so sell
a lot less far and a much more
significant acceleration and then the
valuation story for emerging markets
is really attractive it's not quite half
of what the s
p 500 is trading at but a very
significant discount
and so for all those reasons we're
actually very comfortable with emerging
market positioning
but to the extent that that trade story
started to rear its ugly head again
it could be a very significant headwind
for our emerging market allocations on
the democrat side
the biggie is taxes at the end of the
day that is the thing that we're most
concerned about
with a buy-in win and a dem sweep in
particular
we've done some back in the envelope
calculations based on what he has
proposed so far
um corporate rates going back to 28
percent
from the 21 that they are at right now
we think that could knock off somewhere
in the neighborhood of 11 or 12
of earnings growth in 2021 so when you
think about the next 12 months earnings
growth
we're only looking at about one or two
percent the lion's share of the pickup
and acceleration and earnings growth
is in the second half of 2021 it's kind
of a hail mary
into the end of the year and so if he
were to
institute tax increases of this
magnitude very early in the year
boy that is a big headwind for earnings
growth that
is next to none right at one or two
percent and so
as goes the path of earnings so goes the
markets that's a mantra that we say
over and over again and so um it's not
our base case again because we think the
covid story
will trump um pun intended uh the the
tax hike story there
but it is something that we're watching
very closely a small offset to that
could be
biden's softer stance around trade
policy with china
he has kicked around the idea of rolling
back china tariffs
and so if that were to occur that might
get us back another five or six percent
but it's still a significant net
negative and a headwind to
you know multinational earnings at a
time where it's still very very fragile
in the backdrop and then in terms of
sectors
a couple of usual suspects i don't know
that there's anything here really
revolutionary
um the big one that's been talked about
a lot is really big tech
um likely to be under scrutiny
regardless of who wins you know
the winners are always having the
targets on their backs right
and so at the end of the day what is the
regulatory backdrop going to look like
for mega cap tech and silicon valley
we think it's probably more noise than
news but it's definitely something we
are keeping our eye on healthcare
obviously in the midst of a pandemic but
in any election cycle
healthcare is always in the crosshairs
and so
looking at rising costs looking at drug
price reforms
expansion of uninsured coverage the list
goes on and on and so
it's a headwind regardless of who wins
the election in our view
um and so continue to watching watch
healthcare very very closely
and then the energy story another doozy
um and it really depends on your point
of view
as to whether it's a winner or a loser
so
very very different kind of bifurcated
outcomes depending on who ends
clearly regulations and restrictions
have come down very significantly under
the current administration
but biden supports the new the green new
deal
he supports ending oil and gas drilling
on federal lands
he supports a recommitment to the paris
agreement on climate change and so
for our esg oriented investors our
responsible
investing clients that is a really
important and strong positive and so it
really kind of depends on
your line of sight and your point of
view as to how that may
uh play out in a portfolio context so
again positioning
and exposures definitely matter there